foreign
sorry this was a bit of a last minute
thing for me because I still had a lot
of stuff like a personal chores to do
but uh
yeah we're here I still I'm still not
sure where they're gonna show it because
it there's no schedule for it it seems
and on Twitter there's nothing
[Music]
as of right now
eight minutes yeah
oh hey Nathan thank you
thank you
eight minutes yeah
yeah most of the Zelda tubers are
streaming obviously for good reason
because you know any anytime this game
does show up it's like a blessing
hey izzar how are you doing man
too bad you weren't not you were not a
pack so we've been playing a lot of
Smash there with uh with uh Celtic and
uh HMK and all the guys
I'm sure if you were there you would
have destroyed all of us because
none of us who are particularly like Pro
level but still
yeah I was at Pax
I still have a bit of a jet lag right
now I'm uh and my voice was completely
demolished after that actually it's not
too bad right now but it was it was
horrible when I came home I could barely
talk
because you know how it goes you go out
you you go out for drinks and all that
stuff and you have to scream at each
other because the music's so loud
does anyone know where I can find the uh
the live stream because
it does give a link to it but it just
links to the
uh to the official page
they don't have it on the schedule yet
they haven't scheduled a stream just yet
as far as I know
my last minute predictions I think
they're gonna keep it simple I'm not
expecting anything big but I have been
talking to other people we are expecting
that maybe they'll do like uh
multiple of these smaller ones instead
of just doing like a full hour
they will just cover I think they might
cover like specific things per
presentation spread it out a bit you
know makes the most sense to me at least
because we're now getting really really
close to uh
to release
yeah no live stream
oh it's not a live stream at all it's
just going to be a shadow drop
oh is my audio low
uh that could be it's still set to my
old
settings
uh I can crank it up a little bit
the desktop audio is
quite soft for a reason now I'll crank
it up later when the price presentation
starts
but yeah like the the audio on my mic is
very weird it either like one small tap
and it will just completely here look I
I'm barely moving it and it just changes
like the the volume just shoots up like
crazy
oh hey Conrad
Conrad is stuck in the US from for
longer his flights got canceled twice
actually
I'm using the sure the sure the one
everyone has the Joe Rogan's here
The Joe Rogan mic
[Music]
oh thank you Ryan
hey Don uh put this toward the upcoming
analysis video plural this of this
gameplay demo best sell the channel on
YouTube keep it up thank you so much man
that means a lot
I'm not sure if there's going to be a
lot to analyze like I I've been talking
to others all the tubers before like if
anuma just straight up explains
everything in detail there's not much to
analyze I don't know if I'm gonna make a
video about it afterwards
unless there's like lower stuff in the
background that we can maybe discuss
about or
so we'll see we'll see it it really
depends on what we're gonna see
yeah I guess I'm gonna just be a
refreshing this
so far nothing
three minutes left
I'm not sure if they're just gonna
Shadow drop it on Twitter
I wanted to send a donation uh
because I watch your Triforce video and
oh this morning and it blew me away
looking forward to the gameplay this
more oh yeah it's morning for you for me
it's afternoon late afternoon
uh but yeah uh and your subsequent
analysis
analyzes
well thank you Rin for the win that's an
awesome Name by the way thank you so
much
that means a lot
well there's 500 people watching that's
way more than I expected especially
me being me just last minute oh God I
still have to go to the grocery store I
still gotta watch my because my dog has
uh separation anxiety he needs to go
everywhere with me even when I go to the
grocery store he's just tagging along
because or else he'll just be crying at
home he had a tough time when I was away
for five days at Pax
but he was very excited to see me
immediately stole my hat didn't want to
give it back
I needed to chase him it was really cute
oh hi Sam greetings from the Netherlands
to you sir
West Coast represent
wires Doss and my dog's the exact same
with the separation anxiety is it by
chance a doodle or a labrador some like
some of those types
because they are known for having
separation anxiety like big time
yeah I think they're just gonna drop it
as a video Maybe
because so far we got nothing
normally they schedule it if it's a like
with uh direct they will just schedule
it
but I guess this time they're not going
to do that
Surplus
I'm not sure if I'll watch as I'm uh
upset that I saw red ads in the trailer
so here's some money thank you so much
Surplus
yeah I mean if you want to go blind into
this game I totally respect that like
I might even I might have done the same
if it wasn't for the fact that it's part
of my job now
uh but yeah I totally get it
one minute yeah
oh God I really hope I'm not missing
something
so far it's still there's still nothing
I know a lot of people showed up way
more than I thought there were
because I'm I was really late to the
party
I wanted to stream like an hour earlier
but yeah just life happened
yeah
man this is a sad song I just we should
be more yeah there we go
that's better
here to support you in The Legend of
Zelda refresh yeah I'm refreshing
I wonder if it's really gonna be able a
lot it's probably well obviously it is
pre-recorded but
like 10 minutes is a it's not much
to do as a live stream
oh my god there it is we can throw
snowballs I found it I found the video
okay come on Nintendo show us the money
it's already we're already one minute in
technically
if anyone can find it if uh if I'm
missing something please let me know
it's on the UK
it's there it's up on YouTube like as a
video
on Nintendo of America
are you sure
because I don't see anything yet
home
no
it's on the UK video oh wait Nintendo of
UK
see I oh there we go yeah
what the heck why is the UK earlier all
right you guys ready for this I'll just
crank up the volume
it's 13 minutes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much
yeah there we go
oh my God look at that look at those
buildings there
we have the oh my God this is so cool
foreign
I'll get into the details later because
I can already see something about the
master sword up there too
uh which I guess
in there
so
God my son
we thought they were good enough
okay so weapon durability is definitely
still there
all right
foreign
that is cool
now
I like I like how it's just a giant rock
but when it puts it away it's much
smaller
that is really awesome hi
um
we did not I don't think anyone guessed
this
I'm not going to tell anyone what's
inside the leaks but this was not there
I can tell you that at least
long stick
ERS
the UI is I definitely improved
very useful indeed
I see one of the dragons
oh yeah this is so Zelda Lord got it
right
you can do so many
I can see so much experimentation
that's where the flamethrower thing is
foreign
[Laughter]
oh no he's going to build a boat
oh yeah look at that that's how you do
it all right
so this one ability changes so much and
that and this is just one ability
foreign
I think they're gonna do more of these
to be honest I think this is not going
to be the only thing they do
hi
um
oh so it has like its own stamina or I
guess fuel meter so it cannot spin
indefinitely yeah it's like a battery
thank you
battery powered wood
I was already wondering like are they
going to put limitations on the biggest
Vehicles like they did with the uh with
the bicycle
look at that
um
swiping a korok leaf endlessly
we'll do a little bit of an analysis
for sure
please please do the wall facing
oh it's just like I thought
yeah
foreign
it's exactly like hi
oh this is the puzzles the puzzle
possibilities are endless
this is exactly like like with the
backdrop oh my God this is so awesome
this is so cool yeah
hold on
that's what they call them
is that a door
he just slapped him with the door
that's a door right oh
[Music]
Jesus
there we go the the wow he's showing all
the basics
okay so look at the mini mini map it
changes
foreign
well that is a significant uh change in
speed compared to Skyward Sword
hi yeah in Skyward son it barely made a
difference but here is like like twice
as fast
yeah this is really cool
let's leave it at that foreign
[Music]
foreign
aside
[Music]
myself I spoiled myself
shoot
yeah it's coming
oh that logo
so the it they it was it was correct
yeah it's exactly that
the one from the league
kind of sad that it got spoiled though
[Music]
I think it looks good not gonna lie I
think it looks pretty pretty awesome
[Music]
Nintendo switch OLED model well I guess
I'm glad I didn't get the other OLED
like the the bass OLED
I almost bought it I was I was this
close to buying it I was like and maybe
wait for a little bit longer just in
case
okay so analysis time I guess
UK date order yeah
available 28 yeah
oh yeah the they used the date
differently in in the US so yeah I guess
it's uh analysis time then
uh I think I will just upload it as is
because I don't really see a reason to
make a whole video about it unless I see
things there we go there goes my voice
unless I see things I like in the
background that are
significant but so far it's been pretty
mild it's just the the stuff that we
mostly saw in the teasers
okay so let's go so yeah that's what I
meant you can uh you can see the tower
on Mount lanero and I saw another one uh
well actually let's go with the UI first
I'm I'm very curious what this means
like is this just uh swapping through
materials
because this this is a d-pad for sure
but you can also see the master sword
symbol here
and has an L next to it but he didn't
show anything about that
that's still a mystery like is it going
to charge up as we
collect like energy or are those the
tears of the Kingdom I don't know
but yeah
the UI is still very similar you still
got the the the the sound meter the
minimap
they didn't show the pause menu so
that's also still a mystery
uh I'm not sure
was this in the original I'm not too
sure because I mostly played with the
pro HUD
is was was this uh stuff here was that a
thing
is that like the time of day it was yeah
okay
I think I like from the very beginning I
always played with the pro HUD
so
most things I didn't see unless it was
like other people's gameplay videos
yeah okay oh it's the weather okay yeah
so not the time of day it's the weather
wait are these like coordinates is this
Dev stuff
like these numbers
is that like links position on the map
or something I think it might be a
leftover from the
from the devs yeah I think this one is
the altitude
yeah yeah as he goes up the hill it the
number increases
so yeah uh I'm getting into
game development stuff this was also not
there before
that is
like that that is one of the Stables but
the this like smoke signal that was not
there I I believe
we can see one of those spiral thingies
here again
there's something here that I don't
recognize
here we have a close-up of another one
of those Towers pretty sure those are
shika Towers like new versions of the
shika Towers I've been talking to Celtic
a lot about those I think he did a video
on it to be honest I didn't see that
particular video because I was too busy
that week but yeah
didn't see any Clorox
thank god
well no I'm I hope they are in the game
I just hope that don't have seeds this
time
so we see the land masses up there
I need to reach my friend who is this
oh it is a cool rock he has a backpack
too there we have him
there's a korok
so I need to get to my friend but I'm
pretty sure this has nothing to do with
Clorox if it is I will
hurt this Koran no I'm just kidding
yeah probably a side quest maybe you
have to
like do some sort of
uh
what do you call those yeah like you
have to protect them to it to the next
stable or something like that so here
was a shrine in the original which is
now gone this thing was not here before
the stable looks pretty similar
otherwise some kids playing here doggy
please let us pet the dog
you're probably wondering something yes
can I pet the dog
please let us pet the dog bit I think
this was not here either there's
something pink flowing here that was not
there uh oh that's just one of the
islands
because I think on the other side here
is the zonad ruins and all that stuff
and we know that there's like a thunder
cloud there
I think this stuff is just here to build
Vehicles you can see like planks of wood
so later on when you have the materials
to do it or
like uh
those jet engines you can build a car
out of those so they keep materials
around to build stuff
so yeah there we have one of those rocks
falling down
yeah here's more materials to build
stuff
so stamina still works the same way it's
just so we we do start with a single
stamina wheel again
so link is back to square one
I'm pretty sure we're going to be able
to upgrade those
again
oh wait look
the symbol changed
so it wasn't like before it was like a
symbol of the master sword here you
cannot really see it very well but like
later when he's on the sky islands it's
pretty oh no that's the fuse stuff
that's not the master sword oh I'm an
idiot yeah of course because it shows a
sword and an object so that's the fuse
power so you switch between Powers with
L okay got it my slow brain is just
figuring this out
foreign
yeah the numbers on the map I'm pretty
sure it's just uh that's like for the
either They're Gonna Keep it in but I I
think this is just x y z uh chord and
it's because you can see as he moves up
you can see the number increasing c42 43
so the the last one is the Zed or Z axis
so that's your altitude but I'm sure
they they're going to change that into
something else because this doesn't mean
anything for most people
a few Sky Islands
foreign
let's take a look at link himself I
think he's
yeah it's pretty similar he does have
kind of like a zonai type of bow
it's got that Shield that he's always
carrying uh
yeah you can see here this is the fuse
or this is a Time rewind
symbol so that symbol that we saw on his
hand uh that is the same symbol I'm
pretty sure he had this symbol on his
hand on the Statue too by the way
so that's that's pretty interesting
so that's just that's the recall thingy
and the other one is the fusion one
let's see if maybe by accident he
switches to it to another one we we know
the yeah
the spiral thingy again still not sure
what they're for but we'll see
yes you can repair weapons I'm pretty
sure well we've we can fuse weapons but
I'm not sure if you can also
fix them because he didn't fix the the
the uh the sticks but we'll see
uh okay so he okay so it just hangs
there when you stop the
yeah it just stays there I wonder if it
falls down after a while or if that's
just if it just stays there maybe that's
just how where it was floating before so
I don't know what these are
but do you see the dragon heads here
the zonai dragon heads
they're not the same as the one we saw
in the in the previous game they're
they're slightly different they didn't
have that protrusion up here that
horn-like thing
uh they didn't have glowing eyes
obviously but yeah they are they are not
the same but they're they're similar so
pretty sure it has something to do with
the zonai
oh there's the dragon again
Tower here
's that malice hole that I was talking
about in the underground video this is
one of them you can see it
you can see let me see it boiling up
another Tower here
who is that Dragon though because it it
doesn't look like the other three it's
slightly different
yeah Thundercloud oh yeah
let's go one moment
yeah here's the zonai ruins and all that
stuff just Farren here we have that
thundercloud
let's see here
these are the green spiral things I'm
pretty sure they're just fast travel
points at this stage
it makes sense that once you've visited
one of these islands you want to have a
way to get there get back there quickly
oh actually I want to go go back one sec
because you can see the mini map change
I wonder if it changes
because like here
this part of the map has not been filled
in yet so I guess we have to to unlock
the surface map all over again because
it just so it shows the blue grid and
stuff
so it goes up
and then at some point it's it starts
showing
stays this way
maybe it didn't unlock could also be
that those spiral things are like map uh
related because here the map is still
not visible
but later on like here now suddenly he
does have the map so
I guess once you activate something it
shows up on the map too
uh let's see if we can see anything
interesting in that other shot I'm going
all over the place I know but I'm just
trying to make sense of it all
um there's a floating one of the
floating cubes or labyrinths
hi that we saw
um
that mountain
with the mail is coming out
there are several man-made structures
just like on the surface where did they
come from
yeah I'm sad he didn't go into the
building I want to know what's inside
there
I'm pretty sure it's not a dungeon but
you know you never know
yeah the mini map is filled in now
foreign
so even the stick has yellow leaves
yeah so these are like enemies they're
I'm pretty sure they're like meant to
protect the island but they do have a
purple eye
maybe they're like influenced by malice
again
because a lot of uh a lot of us thought
they were going to be good guys because
of the green energy which is related to
the hand but they do attack link so
they're not totally well technically the
Guardians were also meant to be good
but they got corrupted so maybe the same
thing goes for these ones because they
do have the purple
ish below
yeah it does have a bladed horn
maybe you can turn that into a sword if
you collect it
oh my gosh is that a Zone I swirl
yeah I'm an NBC for the win
yeah so branches still suck they still
break after like five swings
it's so yeah it explodes
he soldiers contract yeah okay for sure
you can make weapons out of these
Soldier construct so that's what they're
called Soldier constructs
so they're soldiers they're meant to
protect these islands
so they're either corrupt corrupted or
they're just doing their job and even
link is not exempt from
from their Wrath
but yeah
zonai charge we got the word zonai
finally
finally so that's like an ancient core
but a zonai ancient core
oh this is so cool
you keep seeing new new stuff yeah here
now you can see the symbol here has
changed so he's now ready to fuse
weapons this is I'm pretty sure this is
a weapon fusing uh I thought it was a
mass assorted uh one point but no
Zone I charge
let's see if we can
see any like descriptions
oh it's so awesome to see the word zonai
in the game
it took such a long time
zone I charge oh my God
so there's not much to see about the the
building itself I think although we do
see that staircase
this uh this might be the same door and
staircase which we see him push open
maybe that's also why the mini map is
filled out because this is probably one
of the first areas you explore so this
is a great Plateau probably
if I had to guess this this is probably
the great Plateau area
Zone I Believers rise
well it's just cool to finally see the
name old wooden Shield
okay so you can
when you target the object you can
choose which object you're holding you
want to fuse it with so you can also
fuse this Boulder with the shield
or with the tree branch which is what
he's gonna do
so because the stick let me see let me
see the controller real quick I think Y
is the attack button in breath to Wild
so you just press that button for the
and obviously The Shield is on ZL
so that that makes sense you you press
whatever thing you want to fuse it with
he puts it away the boulder shrinks in
size
which makes sense I mean the the
model would clip through if they didn't
do that it just pulls it out and it
magically grows bigger
they make like a sort of like a police
siren sound when they see you so they
really are like just protecting the
islands I guess and here you come
bashing their heads in with a boulder on
the stick
another Zone I charge
I wonder if these charges have anything
to do with either the view vehicles or
with
maybe Link's abilities because I I'd
imagine there has to be
some sort of limit to it
I
is there anything in the background no
nothing just trees
yeah
oh it is battery did I miss that part
you use them as a battery
for the propellers and stuff
so most enemies seem to have those uh
things on their head that you can use to
craft weapons later
just like the other enemies these have
them too
uh let's go back one sec
so they collapse
they have like a Searchlight so I guess
they're not corrupted necessarily by
malice
do we still have the master cycle zero I
have no idea seems like kind of
redundant with all the other stuff that
we have now if you can build cars and
your own motorcycles why would you still
have it plus uh the
we did see Zelda with the Chica slate in
the artwork but we don't know how that's
gonna work
uh link churros hack doesn't have it
so the massive cycle zero is a rune it's
stored inside the Chica slate so I guess
it's not there
like no bicycle
uh Rin for the win
again awesome name I guess the Zone I
were more advanced than
breath of the wild had us believe
and that was history Rewritten by shika
royal family
that they were barbaric well I mean we
find the Barbarian outfit in the
shika shrines
so maybe they did or maybe it was just
so long time such a long time ago that
they just didn't understand that these
people were made way more advanced or
the Barbarian outfit has a little to do
with the Zone that's also possible
yeah both both are possibilities
they could have evolved that's also
possible could have also been a split
group because the Zona architecture on
the surface is very different than the
stuff we see in the sky islands could be
that at some point just like the shika
and the yiga there was kind of like a
split some of the zonas stayed behind on
the surface and they
became more like a war-like tribe maybe
even allies with Ganondorf like allied
with Ganondorf at some point we don't
know
and uh the others moved up into the sky
island and built like a whole city there
could be something like that that I I
like the idea of a split because it
worked very well with the yiga and the
shika too
it made perfect sense with them so
maybe they just discovered the power of
the lube
sword by type yeah so this is just your
material list that you can use to fuse
with your bow so you can profuse me no
look at that what happens if you put
meat on the tip of your your arrow
I'm curious
I want to put meat on a stick yeah
lots of new mushrooms here oh yeah let's
quickly take a look at that so
that's a new mushroom I think
this is definitely new uh that I know
what that is I don't know what the
English word is I know the Dutch word
for it
I hate them I don't they don't taste
very well to me
it looks like certain materials like
Amber and stuff are going to be more
weapon shaped so I guess you can turn
this into a spear tip or a dagger or an
arrowhead
you can freeze them with this you can
put the eyeball on there's so much stuff
to experiment with that's just so cool a
leak
is that what it's called a leak I hate
leaks they're terrible
it's one of a few vegetables that I
really despise oh there's the
the thing that the robots have on their
head the soldiers
game leak
oh thank you Raphael
that means a lot
by two jelly
so no item descriptions but
oh this is
so so awesome
now materials actually have more use
instead of carrying a thousand things
with you either most of it most of which
you're just gonna sell for money
or maybe it's a spring onion I don't
know I thought
it looked a bit too big for that here we
are discussing what kind of vegetable
that is oh here's another one
and these
look Zone I made too
that's not the core thingy though
but this one is from I guess from a
different robot model
like maybe a bigger one
yeah
it doesn't matter what kind of vegetable
it is
forget about it forget I I said anything
Now by all means discuss the nature of
this vegetables
this is so Random The Stick of mushroom
to your Shield oh here's that cable
thing that we saw so this is that big
island cluster with the huge building
still it's all the same environment this
has to be the great Plateau area just
makes sense
I said
I think this might be one of the first
areas you will get to explore after link
gets his bracelet thing
so it's just blind at this point just a
smoke grenade
oh you still have sneak strikes
uh Rafael thank you again so much uh
will the master sword fuse with things
I would imagine it could be possible
might be a bit op but
I don't know I don't see why not it's
not like the master sword hasn't been
improved in the past like it's been uh
upgraded to the Golden Master Sword and
all that stuff so
yeah sneak is now much more viable if
you have options like these
we can make ice blades yes
yes
I want to build a Mech I'm sure we can
so here you can already see there's a
sail just laying around here
for sure that's something we can use to
to build rafts and so there's gonna be
materials everywhere
I don't know what this is is there a
club or just a normal stick
doesn't matter
look here you can see one of those rails
oh it it is one of those rails so you're
gonna be Shield
uh grinding on these
because we saw him do that on Death
Mountain in the in the teaser
so these are just going to be all over
the place maybe you can even build your
own like Minecart
put it on Rails too that would be uh
pretty awesome maybe you put something
below like on your Shield
because I can imagine that not all of
the materials are going to be viable for
weapery it's also going to be for
traversal like you stick something on
your Shield to make it more than
aerodynamic or more slippery you can use
it to grind rails or
something like that I can see that
red hand logo in the upper left
oh yeah that's from the uh
that's from from the logo that or that
that symbol that we've been seeing all
over the place
so is is that just the uh
let's see let's see what he does with it
because right before he had the few yeah
here's he's still using the fusion or
fuse thing
and then suddenly it's this and he's
gonna show something new
Rin for the win uh there's a shrine
symbol on the map
oh yeah
I wonder I wonder if that that's one of
those uh spiral thingies that we see all
over the place those rock spiers with
the green
energy coiling around it something like
that
there's also two other symbols that look
like uh some sort of cave
actually maybe we'll be we'll be able to
reference it if we go back to
uh see what it is
see if we can
look like here's one
there's one right here
so that is approximately here at that
River thingy or like a there's a like a
lake
on this
let's see if that's the same thing
it doesn't show up on the mini map there
here there's one like right beside him
but we cannot see that
I think
yeah we're like it's right behind the
camera line uh that sucks you know we're
not not able to see it I guess it's up
here somewhere
they might just be like mini puzzles
like that thing we saw with the motion
controls
but uh good good observation Rin I
didn't see that
so there's
it's up here somewhere like right before
he uses it
I think the smoke will probably be
blocking whatever it is I just want to
know what these represent if they are
shrines or just something else because
shrines were obviously also they doubled
as a fast travel Point too
understand
come on yeah it doesn't show it
Ultra hand
s
yeah so it doesn't show it
doesn't show what it is but we do know
that there's multiple of those spiers on
these islands so it could just be this
one
foreign
like you mean this one right the brown
one
I'm sure these are caves maybe like they
connect to each other because it shows
like a little V maybe like you you enter
the cave from here you exit here like in
the forest
if you've played the the forest then
you'll know what I mean like it shows
like two symbols of a cave
and they connect in some way
up there is that a dungeon symbol maybe
yeah maybe could be
yeah so this symbol is the new Fusion
thingy so that's just what it is
like I thought this was like ganondorf's
hand or like when I saw it in the logo
but now it's just one of the abilities
let's modify the shape of it okay let's
check out the UI real quick yeah I say
unstick
so you use the control stick I guess you
push it in
to uh
like unstick this particular object
you can rotate it
move forward wait what does that say
move forward back okay
the the play bar is blocking I'm
probably gonna download this whole video
later
well I'm sure I'm gonna download it
because I'm going to use the footage for
future videos yeah why not glue hands I
mean why glue hand if you can go Ultra
foreign
state so
yeah
there's something else here let's try
hitting it
I don't think those ancient cores are
related to these though like those Zona
charges because they seem to uh you can
see it like counting down but then as
soon as he stops it just recharges so
it's like like stamina bit like stamina
I think the Zona charges are probably
for something else maybe like that car
we saw there was like a battery on the
car maybe that's
something
related to that
so far I don't see the zonite charges
being used
plus if it recharges on its own you'd
you'd think you don't need that
and you would have to grind for engine
like those cores constantly you have to
go grind and kill those robots I'm sure
they don't want that that's kind of
tedious
yeah maybe for the hot air balloon or
something that has to last a little bit
longer
well yeah there is a limit to how far
you can go
oh there's one of those robots
with the uh lotus flower or pine cone
thingies on on top of them but this one
seems friendly look it's like digging
or gardening but it doesn't attack link
it doesn't even notice him
oh I think I see
uh how do you do this on YouTube again
oh yeah Dot Dot and comma is like frame
going Ranger construct so the other one
was a soldier construct this is a ranger
construct I guess those are not evil
because usually when this pops up above
them that means it's an NPC you can talk
to them
so not not all of them are evil
yeah yeah exactly
you can talk to them
so some of them are just defending
others are just doing their thing I
guess
so there's a building here
this is probably waterfall going down
there's yeah this is just some old
ruined
with materials
the most recent teaser or trailer well
they call it a trailer
we showed scenes of Link riding a large
car and a flying machine
those Vehicles aren't actually aren't in
the game from the start yeah
I'd figured as much because he has that
handle thingy where he could like he
controls it with it
I'm sure that's something you have to
obtain at uh or else you could just go
anywhere you want right from the get-go
that they're not gonna allow that that
would definitely break the game
yeah look at that
look at that wait how does it go from
just sailing to floating all of a sudden
like does it change anything
oh he hits it
and then it just starts floating oh that
that also the stamina
decreases wake way more click quickly
once you do that look
[Music]
so you cannot go infinitely High yeah he
hits it
uh let's see let's see what else we can
find
I'm still curious what these buildings
are for because we've we've been seeing
them all over the place and some of them
have that like those Rings like from a
zen garden
we're gonna
oh here it is here's the symbol for it
like it looks like a link being upped up
uh someone being abducted by a UFO it's
like a beam with a saucer on top
looks pretty funny
uh yeah so he's gonna walk up to this
so there's just an altar here
and it does have that circular pattern
still
there's like an ancient is this like one
of those robots but like uh decayed and
old
looks kind of like it
okay I love how it's
almost exactly like I animated
like obviously mine is much more crude
but
it's almost the same the only difference
is I kept the model inside even though
the patent said either the model will
disappear or you will just see the back
of him
but yeah Link's model disappears I guess
makes more sense to go with that
the model would just the the character
model would just get in the way
that's so cool
like so far have we seen anything
regarding a meter that decreases no
right
so I guess you can just use it whenever
you you're not restricted or anything
does he have the vials on him
they didn't show the vials I think he
does have him right no
yeah he does he does have the vials but
nothing changes
the bow looks awesome by the way that's
a really cool looking bow
no pausing to heal I hope that's the
case because that that was one one of my
biggest complaints about breath of the
wild it didn't make any sense that you
could just pause the space-time
Continuum during a fight and just stuff
your face with chicken legs or whatever
shop icon on the minimap
I have to pay more attention to the
minimap I keep forgetting about it
oh yeah there is a shop maybe that's one
of those uh robots running them because
so far the only living beings we've seen
it's a bit like uh Castle in the Sky
where the only thing left is the
automata because it's
you know automata doesn't age at least
nothing not in the same way
a green spiral as well
you mean this thing here
let's say let's go back inside let's
check the mini map actually just to be
sure
there's a lot of cave symbols
man I love this ability
there have to be there has to be
dungeons in this game right with an
ability like this not having dungeons
that would be such a crying shame
foreign
imagine fusing weapons with shields
ultimate offense and defense yeah oh
offense and defense yeah for sure
for sure
the cave has a check mark above them
well he's gonna go inside one of one
cave in a moment yeah look look
it corresponds so this cave probably
connects to the other cave there
yeah Okay cool so there's gonna be caves
both in the islands and hopefully also
on the surface
uh there's some stuff on the wall
there's another friendly one
who's just hanging out here there's a
cooking pot so we can still cook food
also shows Earth Temple
where
where did you see Earth I am Temple
look at him kick his little link feet
oh yeah when you do the animation I
thought they were gonna go like for a
rock background like that there's gonna
be like a rock wall that's what I use in
my demonstration but this actually makes
more sense can you because you would
have to make a backdrop for every
material that you can pass through
so yeah having a more General one makes
more sense
so yeah we got this we got this we got
this another
floating cube another rail
the previous game you had to use stamina
to climb a mountain well you still do
if there's a mountain with a cave we can
go up
imagine the possibilities I can already
think of like 20 30 locations on the
original map where you could use that
when it's like an overhang or something
or just a straight up cave I want to use
it near the uh
Leviathan skeleton
so yeah you can see another cave here
actually we should check what happens
when he goes back to the surface are
there gonna be any cave symbols then
because that would confirm that there's
caves on the surface too but yeah here
you can see one you can see the cave
here and then you see the the icon
so that's what that icon means I hope I
can reference I would have to study it a
little bit closer but I hope I can
reference what those Shrine symbols are
because so far wait wait
no shoot
okay he gets hit off the island
let's see if there's any time where you
can actually see it on the map
I'm very curious because
Shrine would imply like many puzzles and
all that stuff
but I think it's probably just oh
there's
there's one over there wait no
yeah this is the one that we weren't
able to see
because he keeps us back to the to it
the whole time
I want to know for sure if it's just
those spiral Rock spiral things and it's
just fast rifle points
be a puzzle
connected to it as well
it's just quickly scan the minimap yeah
so this is still the stable you can see
the horse icon
uh
let's see
this way your horses
last scene
yeah so here you don't you don't see the
green spiral yet
maybe that's why it doesn't show up
because it's it's for sure it's this
could be that once you activate them
they become a fast rival point
let's check let's check just to be sure
yeah it's inactive for sure
new horse saddle
yeah I guess
I didn't use my horse all that much to
be completely honest
yeah it's uh
it's a shame like it's up here on this
thing but you can just we cannot see it
and I unless we can find that rock
formation later
that same rock look now he's looking
straight at it but the the fog is
blocking it
those sneaky bastards
you can see the rail on the map too
uh let's see
so yeah it's here that there but there's
also a cave so once you've explored a
cave it just gets a little check mark I
guess
are we gonna see one here
all right
he's looking at it right now
but I think it's
it's
too high it's too high up probably
if I had to guess
oh
is that it
no
no it's more here yeah so it's up there
We're not gonna see it nope
it is funny how this construction looks
like active it has green energy
so let's go a little bit forward I guess
foreign
yeah I don't think we're gonna be able
to see those
there's one where he flies up
oh wait
I think we might be able to see it here
is he's looking straight at it
what is it
come on
ah come on man so it's definitely not
these buildings those are not it which
it was something I thought initially
this has to have some sort of purpose
right
is it up on the mountain again
I think it might be up here oh geez
because the symbol Pops in
just as he starts to lift up
see another one of the spirals here
come on come on come on show me the
goods
no
stuff
yeah they are
important detail Rangers Don't splash
malice when eliminated to me
this is a confirmation that they are
allies
do you mean the soldiers yeah well you
are correct about that the you don't see
malice dissipating so they're just doing
their job they're just defending the
islands
but those are the soldiers the Rangers
are the ones that just hang hang around
they're not doing anything
you can see this shop
yeah you can see the shop here but
does he show it
there's another one of these weird
buildings with the glowing energy
so let's see he
moves to the cave now
let's see what happens
yeah he moves through
yeah shop icon so you can you can buy
things
it's probably just a merchant or
something oh wait do you see that glass
ball
it's like a glass ball on top of a
pillar thingy
I wonder what that does we've not we've
not seen that before
at least not on the islands
is that the shop
at all so he goes over this thing
is
that the shop so is it like a replicator
from Star Trek
punch in what you want to have and then
it just uh creates it for you
let's see
I think it is yeah
I think you guys might be right also is
that a Minecart
are these two Minecarts
you might be able to lift these just put
them on also we didn't he didn't
demonstrate the the new version of
stasis or not stasis uh magnesis which
I'm is understandable because it's just
a rehash of what we already had in
breath of the Wild
these look like Minecarts you could
probably lift them with the magnesis
place them on the rails and go
so we have Minecart racing again just
like in Skyward Sword
yay
but yeah this is the shop apparently
the these people uh had technology that
could just create objects
it's like a giant gumball machine
machine that could also just be the case
if you're stuck in a cage you know what
to do right my scream as loud as
possible
yep
pillars
uh here we see those two
pine cone things again they probably
just lights
they're probably just lights
green symbol is closer to the ridge than
the orb shop is
oh
yeah Lotus blossoms
skyloft Village
that would be an awesome Quest yeah for
sure
there's just materials all over the
place that you can use to build
it just looks so funny
just like a giant ping-pong ping pong
bat just swipes them off
so it just falls off
okay we get Hyrule surface
here's those malice holes two of them
I wish I could turn this annoying bar
off but okay
uh that's one of those glowing drawing
thingies one of the towers
look at that
I love the skydiving stuff I'm happy
it's in the game I hear it's like it's
behind the autoplay button but
oh more of Hyrule
another Tower
more stuff
Death Mountain once again
yeah most of this we've we've seen in
the last teaser trailer whatever you
want to call it those glowing drawings
and
it looks like they toned down the the
Overworld fog
quite a bit
because I'm sure you were not able to
see Hebron this detailed before
it just sticks out for some reason
I might be wrong but
yeah these are we've seen footage of
this island it's from above it's right
above this area
another one of this
wait
what is that is that just a Coliseum oh
yeah that's just a Coliseum never mind
foreign
oh look here the tower is not on Mount
lanero yet could be draw distance but it
is there in other shots
like here
oh
here it is on the on the on the mountain
but in that later shot it's not
so either to draw distance or we have to
activate them I guess
uh here's another island with the with
the pine cone thingy on it because we
saw that also in the other footage yeah
uh
so weird how the towers have just gone
as well as the shrines I wonder how
they're gonna explain that but you know
this is gameplay not Story related
this symbol I'm trying to turn my head
to see what it actually is supposed to
be but
it's not the same they're all different
they're all slightly different
the Coliseum is much closer to the
plateau than the castle Yeah yeah for
sure
where you guys saw a dragon
where did you see a dragon oh the you
mean the the symbol got it
speed up
so you can just Glide whenever you want
that's not how they described it in the
patterns
they said you had to let go of like uh
slow down first and then you could climb
but I think they changed it actually
let's see it let's take a look at the
prompts does anything change maybe he
doesn't have those abilities yet because
I am sure that there was a prompt for
like if you press a you'll turn around
if you uh press the attack button you
might be able to do something you can
use your bow
B obviously is just canceling the the
paraglider
maybe they just excluded it here
get a better look of fahren
there's a thundercloud
foreign
I think they're purposely not going to
show anything about the the surface
because there's no icons whatsoever
accelerate uh
accelerate with r so you can't use the
bow
I think so yeah there's still bullet
time at least in the patents it said
there it still exists but it works a
little bit different I guess
also uh so far I haven't seen
let me really really quickly go back to
this okay so the paraglider does still
use stamina which
I'm not too sure how that's gonna work
because say you want to see if you like
say you get knocked off an island is it
just just game over at that point
you just you're falling down
once you have no stamina left it's just
I don't know
you just have to make your way up there
again
pretty sure that's where the Fast Travel
points are for
it just makes sense for those
Shrine icons to be fast travel points
because again that's how they worked in
breath of wild 2 the shrines
so either there's like a little puzzle
involved
or it's just straight up just you
activate it and and that's it
and it just shows up on your so there's
not a blue blue and orange version
anymore like uh back then
because you could not clear the shrine
but only activate the the the the Fast
Travel point and it would be like two
colors it would be half orange half blue
this one is just straight up blue
so I guess shrines are a thing of the
past or they work differently here
because so far we haven't seen a version
where it's orange or partly Orange
speed upstate
speed up
most of it look at Gerudo yeah sure
let's do that
let's let's do it
do it
um let's see yeah this is where he falls
down I really want to know what those
giant malice holes are if they're going
to lead to the underground or something
else I'm sure they're gonna do another
one of these right
where they're just gonna show more stuff
different things
because 10 minutes is so short
they mostly showed stuff that we already
kind of knew about like the time
reversal stuff the going through
ceilings they just showed the actual
details of it okay so here is he's gonna
move
he doesn't actually show much of a like
of the grudo province
just the very edge of it
as far as he goes and there's a cloud
covering it too damn it
why are they so being so secretive about
Gerudo we haven't seen a single shot of
the Gerudo desert so far
what's going on over there
oh uh I actually want to check something
yet so in the teaser that's in the
middle of Hyrule Field there's another
one of those spiral thingies and there's
also a hole a malice hole
and I think that corresponds with this
one here and I guess here this structure
here is one of those spirals
so it makes sense for those spiral
thingies those spiers or whatever you
want to call them they're they're ever
uh like both on the surface and in the
sky and you can just travel all across
but they haven't showed the actual map
or any of the pause menu
stuff so
yeah we're near the dueling Peaks
which I think was also the case in the
teasers and stuff there's a huge
uh floating land mass somewhere around
the nuclear area
so that's I guess that's this
and that's going to be our version our
new version of the great plateau
here's another one of the spirals
uh not not much to see
when it comes to Farren
these are this is the forest where the
Zona ruins are located
here's another one of those Towers
pretty sure those are chica Towers at
this stage
just watch zeltics video you'll you'll
know what I mean
if you haven't already
no he never turns to the desert
unfortunately
could be part of the death build the the
numbers you mean
how about when he's riding up oh that's
a good one yeah
I I hadn't thought about that that one
let's see
let's see if we see more of hyrule's
landscape while he's riding up hi
I like how everything becomes black and
white it's a neat little effect
oh here's one of the spirals from really
upload I think that's the closest we've
seen them so far
I already saw this one I already pointed
it out before but oh yeah here we go
still you know Gerudo is completely
covered
like on all sides with mountain ranges
look here's a much bigger one
this is the one that he's on later
this is the great plateau
thing
uh pretty sure that's the case
stop
so this is where he goes up for the
first time and then from here of course
we don't see anything because he kind of
It kind of Skips
here's another one of those drawings
yeah so he just goes here and then he
instantly warps to the other yeah here's
the Dragon
could just be Nedra
because you know she she used to or they
used to hang out at laneru
not a no no not what is this mountain
called again it wasn't it like it's not
mountain hylia is it Mount lanero I
think it is
yeah yeah it's pretty sure it's
Mountaineer
the storm cloud definitely has an island
inside it yeah when the lightning
strikes you can see a shape
so yeah
I always mix up Mount laneru and mount
Hialeah which is on the great plateau
here here we see that malice
uh thing again there's multiple of these
so they have to have some sort of
significance
they're not just there for like oh look
again and he's influencing uh
influencing Hyrule
yeah so
this is that big cluster that we saw
before he just instantly warps there
they edit it in a way
unless you're not getting hebra in there
yeah that's true well hebra is easy to
uh to remember because that's a new name
are both
pre-established names
although technically I've no that was
tabantha
which in the Japanese version translates
to Banta
great Plateau is gone really
pretty sure it's still there right
let's check just to be sure in case any
conspiracy theories end up
existing
pretty sure we've seen it in other
footage so it should still be there
oh come on he's not gonna
I think we see it better in the other
footage where he just falls to his death
but not really but you know what I mean
oh come on he barely shows it
come on knock him off
hit him
um
grape Plateau is still there we've seen
it in multiple teasers the only thing
that's gone is the great Forest so far
which we might be like yeah look at that
the great Forest is just straight up
gone
there's even like a new Canyon here
I don't I'm not sure oh no there's there
should be a river here too that's
but the great Forest is around this area
like the the Deku Tree is still just
straight up gone
do you see that
it's just a bald area the whole Forest
is is pretty much gone it's crazy
this is where the tower is normally
uh behind this mountain or right about
here is where the the Labyrinth is
yeah the Deku Tree is just straight up
gone
not sure what happened but uh
yeah because the here's the pond
that surrounds it
just it's just a bald area there's
nothing there
scorched Earth
yeah I'm sure that the great Plateau is
still here
he just doesn't show it here here's the
canyon
wait I just noticed that storm is not
there
see that the the
wait no oh wait maybe it is no
look here's hebra Mountain that that
huge storm that we've seen maybe that
happens later
because right here it's not it's not
present
and we know for sure it's above
because in the other uh teasers you can
clearly see it hanging above it
yeah the
the Decker tree dipped out he's like I
don't want to have anything to do with
this
there's like a huge ring of malice
surrounding it
but yeah I hear that the tower is gone
which is weird
not sure if that's just draw a distance
or if it's just gone or not hasn't been
activated yet
but we'll see
this is also where kakariko villages
about here there's some new
some sort of new formation here that I
don't recognize might be
is kakarika Village like expanding Maybe
looks like scaffolding or something like
that but yeah this is where caprico
Village is
don't remember this either
although to be fair I haven't studied
the whole map prior to this presentation
I'm gonna move
like looks like some of these islands
just only have like a tiny building on
it and then that's it
so
I'm not sure how that would work if you
say you want to reach that Island fast
after you've already been there
is there warp point to that too
yeah the Labyrinth is floating
uh yeah so the castle yeah see Mount
Hebron yeah mount hebra
Habra Mountain
there's nothing there
so that storm hasn't manifested yet but
yet the castle is floating
either they removed it for the purpose
of the the demonstration or it's a story
event that happens later which means
there could be some sort of like a story
uh story progression to it and it's not
just gonna be like all the calamities
all this bad stuff happens right away
and you just go ever wherever you want
like in
I I would say maybe
it's something that happens later in the
game
story progression yeah Dynamic it's a
dynamic world so things change
I don't think he's gonna show much more
after yeah here's Gerudo
um
always
always covered
those damn Highlands
I really like this version of the logo
by the way
this looks so cool more Zona text so it
was actually Zone I text on it
foreign
people are gonna have a field day so
does that does that mean this is also a
new zonai character or is that just a
decoration huh
it's the same text mirrored
yet so it's just I think we've seen this
sequence before
on the mural
so yeah
yeah it looks very clean like I like the
3D look of it
still wondering what those eyes and the
the yeah you know we'll we'll see that's
all story stuff
but yeah so far I'm impressed what what
did you guys think so far
I know it's not much
and many of the things he showed is
stuff that we have seen to an extent but
to see it actually
being used on the spot
like in-game with a proper UI and stuff
I think it's really awesome
and I think I think they're holding back
so much
I'm I'm so certain that they are holding
back a lot of stuff that they because
they didn't show the underground stuff
that we saw in the like with the weird
floating particles it doesn't show
anything about Zelda potentially being
playable or whatever her fate is doesn't
show what those malice holes uh do or
they just wanted to give a taste of what
the game like how it controls and
I think that's already enough for me at
least for now
and I know there's plenty of people who
don't want to get spoiled uh spoiled and
they want to go in blind or as blind as
they possibly can of course because
it's impossible to completely ignore
this game it's not that's just not
feasible
yeah we eating good today
yeah to be yeah to be fair it was only
10 minutes
and I have a hunch don't quote me on
that but I have a hunch that they're
gonna do more of these
just small little short demonstration
not not a actual direct but just small
little Shadow drop so it's well not even
Shadow drops because they did announce
it beforehand but you know what I mean
just
slap it on there
and and go for it
yeah those 10 minutes went by really
really quick
but I mean I'm satisfied I I kind of
liked it it's uh I did the fusion stuff
was completely new we did not know about
that we knew we knew about crafting
because people had already seen that the
arrow stuff with the uh the eyeball
I think there's multiple people who
already witnessed it and and immediately
deduced like oh that's a Key's eyeball
it which I didn't see that but other
people saw oh that's a Key's eyeball so
that's why the whole idea of weapon
crafting came from but the actual Fusion
thing because we saw a link with the
flamethrower on the shield and we never
really got what why is there a
flamethrower on his shield that doesn't
make sense
like is it a shield upgrade is it a but
now we know it's just if you find
something you confuse it either with
your weapon
also explains that stick that he has
where he just shoots some sort of
explosive ball out of it
that's gonna be a major thing in this
game you'll just fuse weapons together
in preparation for fights
which already kind of eliminates a lot
of the issues I had with the weapon door
durability because now you're just going
to be improvising and doing all kinds of
wacky stuff
which means I don't mind as much that
they do break at some point because or
else you would just fuse the most
powerful weapon together and that's game
over at that point why even have the
master sword
a little confusing if you ask me get out
king shade
no your puns are more than welcome here
yeah we didn't see sky combat for
example he didn't show anything
regarding what you can do while falling
down and we already know from the
patterns that there's going to be a lot
like
they already mentioned things like being
able to attack or throw weapons using
your bow turning around
like turning around midair like with
your back towards the surface
so I'm I I think they're gonna do more
of these probably I'll just play the
thing in the background on like while
muted in this uh
in the meantime
but yeah I'm I have a hunch that they
will because they could have done just
like how they did it with breath of wild
just have a full hour
of gameplay
but there's only a few weeks left until
release which I mean is crazy but aside
from that they need something to fill
that Gap
and we might get a one more big trailer
but
I don't expect it to arrive until like
maybe a week before it it launches
but yeah it makes sense to me that in
the meantime like they used to do with
the Smash Brothers where they just had
weekly updates show you more stuff
yeah you could talk to the zonai Ranger
or zonai robot thingy
yeah I can see them doing more of these
short little segments of like 10 minutes
5 to 10 minutes just showing off little
things that don't spoil too much in
regards to story because they didn't
really show any story things
the nothing we saw today had anything to
do with the story which I'm very happy
for because I don't want to know I
really if Zelda is playable in this game
I prefer not to know
because I mean that means we already
know that she's not gonna die or if she
does and she becomes like a ghost then
we already know that too so I I hope
they will save that for the actual game
I don't want to know just don't tell me
about it
did you see the korok near the stable
yeah yeah yeah yeah
because like right before that someone
mentioned Clorox or that we didn't see
korok seeds I was like yeah thank God
and then we saw a core up with it with a
huge backpack I was like no
no no
not again but I don't think it has
anything to do with the
no way Zelda's dying well I mean it's
dying in air quotes because in Spirit
Tracks she technically dies
but it's not permanent she can still be
saved
so I think the most prominent Theory
right now is that she might die and
she's like stuck in the underworld or
something or like half of her lives on
is highly uh the other half goes to the
underworld something of that nature
which I think would be a cool idea
and it also uh fits with the whole
Japanese
Shintoism stuff because in Shintoism you
have a you have yomi which is the
underworld but that's not where the
spirit goes that's where your body goes
like only your body
and your body kind of keeps on existing
as sort of a rotting shell of its former
self like a shadow almost
and your actual spirit either becomes a
Kami or it gets reincarnated in some way
so say Zelda quote again air quotes dies
she could potentially
like exist in two places at the same
time like her body goes down to Hades
whatever you want to call it and the
other half goes up to the sky and
becomes highly incarnate
I don't know just making it just
spitballing here but
there's many ways they could have her
die but not really die because obviously
she's not gonna permanently die that
that would be weird
that's uh that's not a Nintendo thing to
do
but yeah she has technically the uh
technically she has died before
just you know ghosts
if anyone that is dying it's either
Ganondorf or link well yeah Ganondorf is
probably the prime candidate for that
not sure if they're gonna kill him for
good again because that that already
happened twice as well
at least twice it's kind of hard to know
what really happens to him in A Link to
the Past for example
because you shoot him with the Ariel
with the arrow the Silver Arrow it just
explodes
but then in A Link Between Worlds it's
like no he's actually sealed or well
technically he was revived in the Oracle
games in the true ending of the Oracle
games
they summon him again
bringing back bring him back to life but
he's like as a Mindless Beast because
this summoning ritual was not completed
it's a bit of a weird you know it's a
downfall timeline what do you expect
it's uh it's a mess
Brandon's body disappeared at the end of
Twilight Princess well maybe they just
gave him a proper burial
maybe they didn't want to be completely
heartless
Zelda law is confusing well to me the
only thing that's really really that
confusing is the downfall timeline
everything else it just kind of flows
into each other quite nicely
it's well and aside from that also
breath of the Wild's timeline placement
which like is it a dragon break does all
do all the timelines just fuse together
again or not
that's a question for a different time
but Zelda law is not necessarily that
complicated if you don't count the
downfall timeline the downfall timeline
is where it gets really weird which is
also because that that's why most of the
older games are located
uh because some people got on to me for
the fact that I didn't include uh I
didn't include Zelda to the adventure of
Link in my Triforce Theory because I
said like the the Triforce symbol on the
back of their hand it's
it's it was never meant to symbolize
like having the potential to wield the
Triforce it's always been if you have
the mark of the Triforce you have the
Triforce piece
which is true for 99.9 of the time
except Zelda 2 where it suddenly it just
appears on his hand as I think it has
something to do with the fact that the
King cast a spell over the Triforce
and it just made a chosen Hero at some
like someday a chosen hero would have a
mark appear on his hand like first of
all since when can you cast a spell over
the Triforce that's already quite weird
but that whole game is weird when you
when it comes to lore
I respect it for what it did
but the lore is a mess it doesn't even
connect to the original Zelda quite well
because suddenly there's two zeldas and
the Zelda from the original is just gone
never mentioned ever again
but yeah enough about Zelda too
like in that case I just made the
decision you know there's nine eight or
nine games that say yes the Triforce
symbol on on your hand means you have
the Triforce and there's one game that
did it differently which was written in
the late 80s by someone else
and we all know that a lot of stuff has
been retconned before so I chose to go
with the more logical option
foreign
I bet that four Swords Adventures is in
the downfall timeline no actually it's
in the child timeline Triforce Heroes is
in the downfall timeline
but uh four sorts of Adventures is kind
of like the black sheep of the child
timeline in fact most people think if it
wasn't for that game the child timeline
would have been perfect
but yeah
four sorts of adventures also a little
bit wacky when it comes to lore
because we clearly see Ganondorf die and
lose the Triforce of power all that kind
of stuff and then in four sorts of
Adventures he's just reincarnated as
Ganondorf again the same Ganondorf
as a human not as Gannon
and then he becomes Ganon because of a
trident
and vati is there and
this is weird stuff
yeah it's not magnetism did the symbol
change
when he puts on the sale
I guess Ultra hand is
I don't know if Ultra hand is the same
thing as the magnesis if they just
double as the same thing
or if there are two separate powers
because obviously you would still want
to be able to lift things without the
intent of fusing them or creating like a
vehicle out of it
yeah it is called Ultra hand it really
is
very very funny
all the other ones have quite
understandable names like recall so you
recall the time on that object
Ascend I mean that kind of that's kind
of on the nose
but for this one the ultra hand I guess
is what they wanted to go for fuse also
makes sense
maybe because it has multiple purposes
they didn't know how to what kind of
name to give it so they just kind of
changed it
to an abstract name
Ultra hand
isn't Ultra hand of reference to a
Nintendo toy
I think you're thinking about the Power
Glove
the Power Glove is uh well you had the
power
bracelet and the power what was it
called the Titans myth
Titans mitts
it's also a little bit the same thing
yeah the Power Glove
it's so bad
maybe it's because of Laura yeah because
so far we haven't seen that much lore
all we know is that these robot thingies
are defending their islands and there's
good like ones that attack you there's
ones that are passive
uh
the rest is mostly gameplay related
which is exactly what I hoped it would
be I don't want to know too much about
the lore I want to continue to speculate
that's the most fun that's the fun part
of it once you know the answer it's over
that's where it's done is nothing more
to to speculate about
I'm
thinking about doing a video about
the greatest mysteries in breath of the
wild that could be solved in the sequel
something like that just make a little
short list because
I know I'm also working on the sacred
realm video but the sacred realm stuff
is going to take a while to complete I
have to do so my so much research I have
to get into translation stuff
so that won't go up until a while but I
do want to upload content because it's
already been
close to three weeks now because of
packs
so I want to see if I can maybe do a
video but like something related to just
Mysteries
is also a lot easier for me to produce
because I already have most of those
locations recorded I have like nice
footage of the eighth heroine I've
cool angles of the uh the arbiter's
grounds or
the ultrasound toy
I want more info about the Oka I I
wouldn't count on it it's usually not
something Nintendo does is just go back
to old
characters that they've already
introduced before unless it's the Zora
the gorons and all that kind of stuff
like the typical races but
it's very rare for Nintendo to revisit
an old group of people who only who were
only present in one game
but you know I I agree I want to know
more about them but
I'm not sure if they're going to be
connected to the sky islands
we'll see
could be just at the Okawa one time
thing and then it's gone
Ultra hand is an old Nintendo toy really
are you serious or are you just screwing
with me I
I would have remembered it
no thanks Jack
great to hear
Ultra hand actual toy you show the proof
wait I can actually
look it up myself
uh
let me see
Nintendo Ultra I swear if this is fake
oh my God it's real
[Music]
it's actually real
Ultra hand is a toy that was
manufactured by Nintendo in the late
1960s it was created in 1966 by gunpa
yukoi creator of the Game Boy Who Would
later design Love Tester the d-pad the
Game Boy
and the Wonder Swan what's the Wonder
Swan I'm not I'm not going to get too
deep into that rabbit hole Ultron
consists of multiple or several
crisscross connector plastic elements
and upgrade as lazy thought that's just
well I mean they used to be a Toy
Company because so I guess that makes
sense but still
this already existed before right
oh it appears in WarioWare titles
blah blah blah blah Mario Kart super
Circuit
it's also a decoration behind the
counter in the bomb shop in Majora's
Mask 3D
oh geez well my apologies you were right
it is a thing it does exist exist it's
an actual thing
you got it
yeah arms is kind of like that too I
guess
bro Nintendo made something called a
love tester
yeah
I don't think I want to know more about
that
to be completely honest
but yeah
I think I'm gonna call it a day soon uh
folks because my my dog needs a walk and
uh
you know chores life things I'm not sure
if I will make a video of uh like about
this whole ordeal because there's so
many little details but none of them are
like super significant when it comes to
lore
and the gameplay kinda speaks for itself
and we've already gone through it
with this whole analysis too
so I'm not sure if it's worth it to to
actually create a whole video plus
Celtics is going to be way faster than
all of us anyway he's gonna have his
analysis up hours before any of us will
and uh banded games he's also very quick
usually
so I think you know we had a successful
stream we had a lot of viewers we've
been like analyzing a lot of stuff
if you find anything you can you know
send something to like on Twitter or
post a comment on my latest video
I'm just gonna be thinking about what
I'm gonna do with this but I'm not going
to be in a hurry to just put out quick
content because I suck at doing quick
content
it's just not my thing
when I do quick content I always regret
it right after
so but yeah
I'm very very yeah Nintendo well
Nintendo black crisis also is he prefers
to take his time to he will be the guy
that comes like two maybe one or two
days after the fact but it's like a 40
50 minute analysis in depth he's got all
the information so he got the quick boys
and you got the the very thorough boys
I'm one of the more thorough boys I
guess
but for this one I'm not too sure if
it's worth making a whole video about
or if I just maybe I'll do a little top
five little details
hey there's the dragon again
but yeah maybe like a top five little
details that I found significant but I I
don't see myself making it
like 20 minute video out of this
I know it would sell probably and it
will get the views but I just don't I I
just don't care man
I just want to be happy with what I put
out
and HMK comes through with the crazy
hyper oh HMK is such a great guy by the
way I've met him in uh during Pacs and
we we were in the same Airbnb and we
hung out like him and his fiance are
just they're so nice
like he if he uh
he was I think the no there was one
other person who also brought their
girlfriend or fiance with them
under normal circumstances I would I
would be like
you know it's a house full of guys but
she was like straight up from the moment
she walked in she was just one of the
guys I she's one of the people I spoke
to the most she was awesome
really really friendly
did some awesome cosplay too we had the
same music taste
like all of them were great Celtic was
also very very friendly I got on with
him of course Conrad I already knew I've
been to Poland with Conrad before so
that was not the first time meeting him
it's a shame Nintendo black crisis and
Dr Wiley were not there and Zelda Master
also wasn't there because he's like in
Korea or Japan right now no not Korea uh
Taiwan I think he
he's really awesome
but I haven't been able to uh meet him
who's HMK he's like one of the OG Zelda
guys yeah he also does a lot of Kingdom
Hearts
like you either like his energy or it's
a bit too much for you but
that guy is just
like uh
that's one thing I noticed he's as
energetic in real life as he is in his
stream so it's not like just a facade he
really is super
uh super energetic but also very
friendly like it was super cool
and there was there were other people
there too that were also uh
very everybody everybody was nice
was my first time on
on American soil so
it was just a very interesting
experience for me
thank you
did you and Conrad go to Japan together
no that was Conrad and
nintendon
yeah nintendan which is
you write it differently it sounds
similar but
Don and Don are two different names
is Don d double a n and my name is d-o-n
so but yeah also by the way also a nice
guy Nintendo I didn't meet him at Pax
but
I've talked to him before
he's Dutch too yeah Nintendo like that
but yeah it was a it was a great time
Pax was uh very interesting experience
for me
first time on American soil first time
meeting a lot of the people oh I totally
forgot about Bandit games oh my God
that's so embarrassing because I I
talked to him probably
most of the time when we went out
also such a cool guy
like Bandit games is genuinely super
nice it's very laid back
foreign
like I said all of them were great so
I'm I'm bound to forget
some of them
or forget to mention them at least
I'm a bit sad that you can't drive and
explore the world on the water
well we don't know that we don't know if
that's the case
I think they're hiding a lot of stuff
from us
maybe there's an outfit that does let
you swim underwater like the Zora outfit
like what the Zora outfit was supposed
to be
I'm 100 sure that what we saw today was
just a little
you know something to hold us over to
get us excited again but they are
holding back a lot of stuff
I can't go into details about any leak
stuff so I'm not gonna talk about that
but uh yeah from from what I have seen
so far and from The Impressions that
I've gotten
they're holding back so much
this game is gonna
absolutely blow everyone's mind when it
comes out
I'm more and more certain that there
will be dungeons that there will be
something big
uh some like underwater exploration is
definitely not out of the question at
all
there's so much potential to to this
game and they're only showing us the
stuff that they absolutely want us to
show
I want us to see I mean because I know
for breath of the wild the development
team didn't want to show much either but
it was kind of like the marketing team
that forced it on them like no we have
to show this game because it's a switch
system seller I think if it was up to
anuma they didn't show anything like at
all
they would just
drop the game on release and be like
well here it is guys
have fun
maybe Laurel in Village will finally
have a use yeah maybe
I hope so because it's one of my
favorite places in breath of the wild I
like tropical settings so for me
when I found that place I was very happy
yeah the breath wild team really
disliked how breathtwild was marketing
for sure yeah and I I understand that
because you you want to have a sense of
mystery too
it's the same with movie trailers you
know uh you give away too much the whole
movie is basically ruins you give away
too little it doesn't sell it doesn't
get people into theaters
but there have been marketing tactics
where they do
show very little and it does work like
Cloverfield for example
if anyone remembers that movie uh
that trailer got people into theaters
because they showed almost nothing
I think it was just a couple of people
running onto the streets and the head of
the Statue of Liberty rolling down the
street and some explosion in the
distance or something like it was very
vague they didn't let us know anything
about what is it what it was about
and it it worked it got people excited
so in some and you know if if they had
shown the monster in the trailer right
away
it wouldn't have been the same
Red Dead Redemption 2 also suddenly
dropped yeah
I know people want to know if it's
something that's worth going to be worth
uh spending their money on
but at some point you also just have to
look at track record and Zelda I mean
come on it's Zelda
Linda has there ever been a bad Zelda
game like a genuinely bad Zelda game
like not like controversial or divisive
like
apart from the CDI games
I cannot point to a single Zelda game
that's actually bad maybe not for
everyone
but yeah not bad bad
well even four Swords Adventures I
played it recently it's a really fun
game it's really good and Triforce
heroes from what I've heard people who
have played it with friends which is
what it was actually made for it was
really fun and it's good and it works
fine
and four Swords Adventures although the
lore doesn't make sense it's still
pretty wacky how far they went with the
lore
yeah Link's crossbow training I guess
you could say that's a bit of a failed
experiment but
it's not a it doesn't have the legend of
prefix so it's not it's not even part of
the Zelda timeline
but yeah thank you all so much for uh
for showing up and uh I hope you guys
are more excited now if not I'm sure
there will be more and
I think um
I think we will get that final big
trailer
that big 2017 breath Wild trailer like
that kind of thing
they have to
but yeah I really have to go walk my dog
make sure he's uh he's happy he's a
happy boy because he he missed me for
five days and he was so sad
so I'm just gonna
pay to pay some attention to him
this ended up being a way longer stream
than I thought it would be
yeah thank you uh thank you Cassandra
thank you everyone for showing up and uh
look forward to more videos in the
future
I'm not gonna say what I'm gonna cover
but there will be more very very soon I
gotta get back into into the groove
anyway so yeah
yeah fingers crossed from future
trailers and more gameplay
demonstrations all that kind of stuff
thank you all so much
for choosing My Stream
and uh yeah I love you all and uh see
you next time
bye-bye